welcome back okay up until now we've
been talking about balance truncation
which is an effective strategy of model
reduction so if you have a lot of high
dimensional system with a lot of states
and you want to get a reduced order
representation in terms of the most
important States so that you can control
it faster we can use balance truncation
so the basic idea here is I have some
coordinate transformation x equals TZ x
or my original coordinates Z or my new
balanced coordinates and to use my
balancing transformation this is an an
invertible square matrix T so that in my
new coordinates my controllability
granion equals my observability gramming
equals diagonal matrix where these
diagonal entries go from biggest to
smallest
so most controllable and observable to
at least controllable and observable
that was the whole framing of a balanced
balance truncation until now and if you
remember one way that you can actually
derive this T transformation is I could
take my controllability graeme and from
my original system in my coordinates x
times wo
again my observability graeme and in my
original coordinates X and I could
compute the eigen decomposition of this
super big n by n matrix of graeme ins
now it's super interesting math that you
can do this the balancing transformation
it's rock-solid we've worked through it
all we coded it up it works but
computing graeme ins is extremely
expensive these Grammies the way people
normally compute them is as the solution
of a Lyapunov equation which I think
scales something like order and cubed or
it's really an ugly scaling to get these
so if n is big even moderately big like
ten thousand or a hundred thousand or a
million computing these W OS and WCS is
very very hard at all most intractable
and computing the eigen decomposition is
also really nasty okay so long story
short this works great for moderately
large systems like maybe I have a
thousand degrees of freedom back when
this was developed people were thinking
about things like aerospace structures
like the space shuttle
or the International Space Station and
the Hubble Space Telescope or you might
get these vibrational modes in the
structure but you could write down a
pretty decent model in terms of maybe a
thousand or a few thousand components
okay now we're thinking about applying
these to much bigger systems in
turbulence neuroscience disease modeling
where you might have millions or
billions of degrees of freedom and so
going through this kind of standard
procedure of computing your graeme ins
and then balancing is intractable okay
so there were a lot of innovations
remember this was more 1981 and so I'm
gonna tell you in the next few lectures
about some of the major innovations that
came afterwards that made this tractable
for very very large systems with a huge
end okay so to get into the nuts and
bolts of how this actually works I'm
going to introduce a system I'm going to
switch to discrete time the only reason
I'm switching to discrete time is
because the matrix math becomes a little
bit simpler I don't want you to think
too hard about this okay what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have X at time
step K plus 1 equals some discrete
version of my a matrix times X at time k
plus B U at time K and what we're gonna
have is y equals C at time K as well
okay good and I think something else
important here is looking at the adjoint
system okay so the adjoint system here
this is this is basically my dynamics
written in discrete time so time step K
delta T and these a B and C matrices are
different than my original a B and C
matrices but there's formulas for how to
get these and if you want to do this in
MATLAB there's a super simple command
called
C to D continuous to discrete or you can
go check the control bootcamp for how to
go from a continuous time system to a
discrete time system anyway I'm just
this will make it a little bit easier
this is my direct system I have
something called an adjoint system so a
lot of what I'm going to tell you about
right now
is applicable to systems that you can
simulate in a computer where you have
the equations of motion but they're
really big so if I have these equations
of motion I can write down an adjoint
system I can't do this in an experiment
this I can do in an experiment I can
have a high dimensional nonlinear system
that I can control and measure but what
I'm going to show you now is only doable
in simulations so what I could also do
is I could define a new system XK plus 1
and basically I'm just going to
transpose everything so now this becomes
a complex conjugate transpose XK plus
the complex conjugate transpose of C
times YK and I'm actually going to just
even erase this output equation so for
now all we're thinking about is big
simulations maybe I can simulate the
climate or a disease spread or a
turbulent fluid so I have a big
simulation code that can do this I can
kick it with use and I can measure wise
so if I give my system an impulse in you
I can measure how that rings through the
dynamics of the system X and then this
adjoint system this is called direct my
adjoint system is basically if I complex
conjugate transposed my dynamics then my
output Y becomes the input input in
these adjoint equations and what I can
do is that kind of this thought
experiment and numerical simulation
where I impulse my measurements Y and I
see how it in kind of adjoint dynamics
those ring through and lead to a state X
so this isn't forward time and backward
time but the way I kind of think of it
is if I kick you I measure what happens
in time in X and if I and then what this
adjoint system tells me is what states
are most most excite my measurements Y
so if I have like a delta in my
measurement Y what is the state's
history and time that most excites that
measurement Y this is a mathematical
construct you can only do this in
simulations this is fine in experiments
you need simulations to do the adjoint
stuff so everything I'm telling you
about is model reduction that people
generally
you in high-performance computing
contexts okay good
remember fundamental central challenge
let's write down the central challenge
is that I don't want to ever compute WC
or wo or do this n by n eigen
decomposition this is nasty
ok computing these Li happen of
exponents is really terrible so what you
do instead is you use basically impulse
responses of the direct and adjoint
system now remember what an impulse
response is let's say I have an airfoil
I have some some airfoil I'll see if I
can still draw an airfoil ok airfoil
what an impulse response is as at time k
equals 0 I'm going to impulsively kick
the system I'm going to impulsively kick
it maybe I'll give it an angle of attack
or something like that and then I watch
how the dynamics evolve through the
states of X so I impulsively kick this
thing up and then I measure how the
dynamics go through the state X in time
so this is a movie now of how the state
is evolving in time after I kick the
system that's an impulse response
impulse response and the kind of bizarre
thing is you can do an adjoint impulse
response I can take this little
imaginary measurement maybe I have a
maybe I have a sensor here and what I
can do is I can give this an impulse in
that sensor in this adjoint system and I
can measure what States what the
dynamics is due to that and what state
history maximally informs that
measurement very interesting stuff and
if I do this what I end up getting are
these two matrices that essentially look
just like the controllability and
observability matrices from the control
bootcamp before ok so I had this curly C
and what currently C in discrete time if
I give this thing a delta function an
impulse at time 0 with 0 initial
condition my state history starts
looking like it's an impulse so it looks
like B then it gets multiplied by a then
it looks like a B that's what X looks
like at the night next time step then a
squared B dot dot dot and then a to some
power M B
and I'm just you know I'm basically
going to kick my system and I'm gonna
watch em frames n plus-1 frames of this
movie evolving and each of those I'm
going to stack into a tall column vector
of dimension n into this big matrix so
this is a big matrix every column is a
state of my system as time increases
after my impulse response and I can do
the same thing with this adjoint system
and I get this thing called the
observability matrix this is kind of the
discrete-time version of the
observability matrix which is c CA dot
dot dot c a again to the M power so this
is kind of cool what we find is that I
can you know I have my high dimensional
system but I can conduct experiments
numerical experiments simulations I can
give this thing impulses in my out in my
inputs you I can give this thing
impulses in my sensors Y and I can
construct these two matrices this
controllability and observability
matrices purely from simulation data so
this is still data driven driven by a
simulation and so now what we're going
to be able to do is approximate these
gray means these were really hard to
compute using the Lyapunov equation so
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to say that WC is approximately
equal to this controllability matrix
times its complex conjugate transpose
again for real matrices this is just a
transpose and wo is approximately I
think it's Oh star Oh again complex
conjugate transpose for real matrices
just to transpose so C times C transpose
au transpose times oh and you can verify
for yourself basically what I would like
you to do is kind of an exercise or a
homework is write down C times C
transpose multiply it all out and verify
for yourself that this actually looks a
lot like the terms in the
controllability gram in okay so this is
in discrete time so there's a few
caveats here remember my controllability
and observability gram Ian's are smooth
integrals from time equals
zero to infinity so this will be a good
approximation this is good when two
things happen when the delta T is small
so I remember I'm doing this
discrete-time system when I have a
really small delta T I'm essentially
getting a riemann approximation of that
integral of the grammy and using these
products and that riemann approximation
will get better and better when my delta
T is small and when M is large so
basically when I have enough snapshots
that I'm actually approximating this
integral from T equals zero to infinity
okay so I'm basically doing a remodel
summation of my Grammie ins and if I'm
at my delta T is small and I integrate
for long enough I get a good
approximation and this is really cool
because what this means what this is
what more should basically Moore in 1981
showed that I can construct these these
are called your empirical Graham Ian's
okay these are empirical Graham Ian's
because they're data-driven you run a
simulation of your direct and adjoint
system you get this and this and you can
build these approximations of your
Graham Ian's without ever doing a
Lyapunov equation solve which is really
really expensive so this is believe it
or not cheaper than what people were
doing before then I can multiply these
and find T and more also built in that
you could use the principal component
analysis to essentially get expressions
in terms of the dominant principal
components of these structures so it's
interesting more still went through this
procedure and constructed n by n
controllability and observability Graham
Ian's and then computed an N by n T
matrix so that's still very expensive
for large n it's this is a way of doing
it but it's still very expensive Wilcox
and Ferrari in 2002 essentially showed
that what you could do is compute a rank
R truncation of these Graham Ian's
before you compute this eigen
decomposition so instead of computing
this n by n huge matrix rank n
invertible T matrix they compute like a
rank R approximation and only directly
get the our most important columns of T
because that's all we wanted in the
first place we're gonna truncate this so
we're computing this T just so that we
can throw away most of the columns and
only keep the first R components and so
this was a way of basically accelerating
that and not wasting a bunch of
computational effort computing all of T
but then afterwards in in 2005 Raleigh
Raleigh 2005 essentially showed that you
could kind of bypass even cooking up
these Gramm Ian's in the first place and
that's what I'm gonna tell you about now
so these are both both of these methods
are called BPO D and these are both very
kind of important additions after more
1981 these made it so that you could
scale to big systems I'm gonna show you
about kind of this method where you
don't have to compute any gray means at
all I encourage you there's a lot of
stuff that happened between 1981 and
2002 so I think you had worked by Lal
and Marsden and glove ASCII and and
others lots of interesting work from
there to there I'm oversimplifying
history here but really these two papers
are where this scaled to very hard heart
high systems BPO D means balanced proper
orthogonal decomposition proper
orthogonal decomposition is just what
physicists call principal components
analysis so it's it's it's all connected
good okay so now I want to tell you
about essentially how you would do this
without ever computing any gram units
because this is at the end of the day
what's actually important to us is not
is not actually computing gram ian's
okay
good
okay so we're gonna we're going to
essentially find the leading are columns
of tea that the stuff that we want the
the balancing transformation into these
balance coordinates and we only want the
first are columns of this because we
want a reduced order model of rank R so
what we're going to do now is instead of
ever cooking up these Graham Ian's we're
going to work on this assumption or that
this this innovation that I can
basically directly take the singular
value decomposition of Oh times curly
see the controllability matrix so
instead of building these empirical
Graham Ian's or a rank truncated version
of these empirical Graham Ian's what I'm
gonna do directly this is what rally did
was I'm going to compute my direct modes
I'm gonna compute my adjoint sorry my
direct impulse response and my adjoint
impulse response stack those into
matrices see and Oh curly C and curly oh
and then what I can do is I can multiply
these directly and I can just BAM
multiply them together and work only in
terms of this quantity here to get my
reduced order model and this is called
balanced proper orthogonal decomposition
or BPO D and remember P OD is just
physicists way of saying PCA they're
kind of all based on the singular value
decomposition
okay so SVD PCA APO de and there's about
five other names for this because it's
that important many many people have
developed this for four fields along
along the way ok so right now what we're
doing is we're trying to compute the
leading are columns of the balancing
transformation T using this product Oh
times C now what's cool is you can write
this o times C if I actually expand this
out what I get is now this is gonna be a
little crowded okay so o is CC a dot C a
to some power and curly C remember this
is my system matrix C it's different
than curly c curly C is B
a B dot a dot a to some power and B okay
and if I write this if I multiply this
out these have the right dimensions that
I can multiply
inner dimensions match so I can multiply
this out and what I end up getting is
this big matrix that's called a Hankel
matrix H now remember our Hankel
singular values that's going to come
into play here so I can multiply this
out and I get a c.b.c a b dot c a b c a
squared b this will be c a cubed b and
so on and so forth and so on and so
forth so CB c a b c a squared b c a
cubed b and so on this is just a big
symmetric matrix called the Heinkel
matrix
let's put that henkle very important
should be reminding you of the Hankel
singular singular values okay
and so this henkle matrix we're going to
come back to this later when we talk
about the eigen system realization
algorithm but I just want to plant this
idea in the back of your mind
we built our controllability matrix and
our observability matrix assuming that I
could measure my full state X and I
could run this adjoint simulation so
we're doing this in a simulation where
we can measure the full million
dimensional state X as it evolves in
time and we can run this non physical
adjoint simulation to get these two
things but what's really cool and we're
going to come back to this when we talk
about eigen system realization algorithm
so let's just put a little note in that
eigen system realization algorithm will
be a lecture in a few a few lectures if
I gave an impulse in U and I just
measured why I couldn't measure the full
state X but I I could kick the system in
you and I could measure my measurements
Y this would essentially be Y at time 1
Y at time 2 y at times 3 so on and so
forth this would be y at time 2 y at
time 3 dot dot dot dot and so on so I
can long story short I can actually
compute this Hankel matrix from real
experimental input
data without ever having access to X or
my adjoint system okay and so we're
going to talk about that in in the
experimental context later in terms of
erm but for now we're going to assume
that we have access to our equations we
have access to adjoin equations we can
measure the full state and we have these
big big data big data matrices okay okay
this is pretty hairy okay we're gonna
fill up the whole board so what we're
gonna do now is we're going to take this
Hankel matrix and we're gonna take its
singular value decomposition
okay we're always going to rely on
singular value decomposition to make our
lives easier so we're gonna say this is
U Sigma V complex conjugate transpose
star just a transpose for real matrices
and what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
decompose this into different different
components I'm gonna say there's u tilde
the stuff I'm gonna keep the first are
columns of U and then all the stuff I'm
going to truncate this is just like what
we did before my Sigma matrix is
diagonal these are my Hankel singular
values my H s V's my Hankel singular
values I'm gonna have Sigma tilde and
all the Sigma stuff I'm going to
truncate and then finally I'm also gonna
have V how do I want to write this I
want to write this as a column of V
tilde star and then all the stuff I'm
going to truncate no tilde just truncate
okay so basically what I do is I can
this is my direct impulse response this
is my adjoint impulse response okay I
just compute these in a computer my
direct and adjoint I multiply them
together to get a Hankel matrix and I
take the singular value decomposition
and basically the singular values here
are very very related to these diagonal
elements and my balanced granion here
okay so these are the same Hankel
singular values there and this again
then tells me how do I chop this system
up to only keep the first are poor
this model okay whoo all right a little
bit longer we're gonna write down the
last the last step now okay remember I
just wanted the first our columns of T
and it's inverse and so that's what I
get here so now what I can get is my
direct modes I think in the past what I
did was I called these sigh so website
equals is it equals curly C times V
tilde times Sigma tilde to the minus 1/2
there's some math you can you can kind
of convince yourself that this actually
matches what you got with balance
truncation that's a really nice exercise
or you could read about it in rally 2005
it's really nicely outlined there it's
also in our book ok and then you can get
our adjoint modes and we're gonna call
these fee and fee are gonna equal curly
o star u tilde sigma to the minus 1/2
okay so these are literally the first
are columns of this balancing
transformation and these are the first
are columns of the inverse transposed
and then the last kind of the punchline
of all of this is that I can use these
to actually get my reduced order model
so I'm just going to show you how you do
this because it's super nice then what I
can do is I can say okay a tilde B tilde
C tilde equals okay I'm gonna recap in a
minute so if you're feeling like this is
just overwhelming we're gonna just do a
recap this equals V transpose times my
original a times I this equals fee star
B and this equals C times sy and I think
if you go back to the balance truncation
lectures that's exactly what we what we
found is that if I take the first our
columns of T and I call those sy and I
take the first our columns of the
inverse and I call those fior if you
start
or whatever then this is how you get
your reduced order model this is my my
order our reduced order model okay so
let's do a recap this is really cool so
why did we go through all of this math
we went through all of this math because
although Moore had the right idea of
finding so before more people didn't
think of degrees of controllability and
observability there are these rigid
definitions of it is controllable or it
is not controllable what Moore said was
there are degrees of controllability
that are given by kind of these
directions of the graeme ins okay so
more allowed us to hierarchically
arrange our state space in a new
coordinate system so that we could get a
reduced order model in terms of the most
controllable and observable directions
in state space that gives us a reduced
order model that we could do control
with but that involves computing these
gigantic and by Engram ian's which is
ridiculous we don't want to do that so
what more did was he said okay if you
have a direct system and an adjoint
system and you can collect data from
these measurements you can approximate
your Graham Ian's and you can do this
procedure still very expensive so
wilcoxon pereira
said well i don't have to compute this
entire rank and and by n grammy and if i
only want the first are columns of T to
get psy so they did a rank R truncation
of this and then Rally 2005 kind of came
up with this expression that you didn't
actually have to work with these
empirical Graham Ian's at all what I
could do is directly work with this
Hankel matrix o times C and this is a
lot better because this you know o is a
lot smaller than these Graham Ian's and
C is a lot smaller than these Graham
Ian's when I multiply them together I
get this Hankel matrix I can take the
SVD and I can get a reduced order model
okay so you still need a direct and
Agilent simulation you still need to
collect that data but then you can build
this Hankel matrix SVD it and get your
model directly so this is a pretty
streamlined procedure to getting reduced
order models without ever building these
grand
it's okay so one of the things we're
going to talk about next is I drew this
red dot that was supposed to be my
sensor why and I had you is like the
angle of attack of this airfoil but in
many systems the measurement Y is
actually very high dimensional I can
measure the whole state X so I might
have a million measurements I can't do
an impulse response in every single one
of those million pixels or million grid
points in my simulation
I can't store a million impulse
responses so in the next video I'm gonna
tell you about what Raleigh did in 2005
to handle that case where my number of
outputs was massive okay so to kind of
bypass doing this this observability
impulse this this o impulse response for
a really really high dimensional output
data okay
still data-driven you have data you get
models but it's based on an equation you
have to have access to the equation okay
thank you